well let's bring in greg sim he's chief
executive of the international security
company glassful solutions so Greg how
serious is this particular attack do you
think well as a serious attack as you
can tell I mean it's spread globally Ian
and is it surprising probably not a
start in Ukraine allegedly our
intelligence a people tell us that it's
likely to have started through an email
through an attachment or a link with a
Microsoft Word document and that's so
easy remember that these things can
actually trigger how the infection
started how the beach head has started
so how the companies and individuals
protect themselves and is it something
as straightforward and simple as just
not clicking on an attachment that looks
dubious that sounds awful easy but
remember that the the clicking on the on
the email or the attachment it ranges
from the very simple you know you always
say you can't you can't insure against
humidity meaning you see something that
doesn't look right it doesn't feel right
unfortunate some people still click on
them all the way up to the ones are very
sophisticated that that targeted that
the structured to come from an
individual that you think is a friendly
or the spoof tease email and the chances
are you're gonna you're going to tuck it
and the way that companies have got to
approach this now is to be looking more
into innovation it's clearly showing
that traditional methodologies of trying
to prevent these attacks are just not
working they're simply not working now
we've had a couple of these lately we
had an attack on the NHS a few weeks ago
at the weekend Westminster came under um
prolonged assaults why are we suddenly
getting a big spate of these attacks
well simply because it's it's not very
difficult for the Tucker and you've got
it a member who's who's really behind it
when again the early news that we've
seen is that the Luke and a three
hundred dollars worth of their bitcoins
and now in the face of it you think well
why why would you want to do an attack
like that and only gain three hundred
dollars worth so then does your mind go
to a state driven attack that I remember
talking and your program children the
NHS where we spoke about if you wanted
if you were going to be a state a state
driven attack and you want it to create
fear and havoc well you've just done it
so the the next thing is you know power
power
companies have been hit when to the
lights go off and ironically the Ukraine
just twelve months ago had a systemic
attack against the power grid that took
down a whole suite of a country all
right Greg symfon glass wall solutions
we've got to leave it there thanks for
joining me